my name is Elizabeth Hopkins and I'm a
student at the garrison fire school in
owings mills maryland hi I'm Alex
d'agostini and I'm I attend crespi high
school I'm from Thousand Oaks California
hi I'm Caitlin wedding and I'm a junior
at wakefield high school and Arlington
Virginia hi i'm sarah carlson i attend
lisbon high school in Lisbon Iowa and I
man Nicholas welcome to close up forum
there's been increased interest over the
last several months and the
assassination of John F Kennedy
especially with the release of a motion
picture on the subject some of the
public interest focuses on several
conspiracy theories that contradict the
official warren commission report that
was issued by the government last week
CIA director robert gates announced what
he'll call an openness policy at the CIA
and part of that involves releasing
documents that were previously sealed
that relate to the assassination we'll
hear from our panel of high school
students about what they know about JFK
and the assassination and later in the
show we'll talk about the term
electability and how it relates to
political candidates first I'd like to
get just a general idea of what kinds of
things you learn in school about Kennedy
and about his administration and about
the assassination attempt katelyn if we
could start with you well in my American
history class we haven't gotten to the
assassination of JFK yet but I read
through the history book and I'm in a
college-level course and my book is
vague in a lot of areas where he thinks
that you should know about the subject
he doesn't the authors Thomas Bailey he
doesn't really explain it that well and
about this isn't very long i'm just
going to read this one thing this is
what it says this is all it says about
the assassination so bizarre with the
events surrounding the two murders that
even an elaborate official investigation
conducted by Chief Justice Warren could
not quiet all doubts and theories about
what had really happened so he sort of
presented that there was controversy
about what happened but I don't want to
get into it so if you want to learn more
about it go look it up someplace else
and so where we get another book also we
were issued two books and so I looked in
that book as well and that sort of
intimated that there was a lone gun
theory and a
two man theory and a conspiracy but
there wasn't enough evidence after war
and report to go ahead and prosecute so
from the books that's what you what I
would learn but through my parents and
through other class discussions and
other things that I've read I have a
deeper knowledge than just that but just
going from the books it's very slight
and doesn't talk about the controversy
and just sort of it says that Oswald
acted alone and he shot Kennedy have you
had any discussions in the classroom or
has the teacher talked about it at all
about the assassination not as of yet in
this class but I have had discussions in
other classes about it what kinds of
things are brought up do you hear about
different theories that are
possibilities oh yeah and about the CIA
and about the cover-up the possible
cover up and if it was a lone gunman and
things like that but also we talk about
more the repercussions of the
assassination and the attitude and I
mean the repercussions of people's
attitude and people's that faith in
government but just how it was so
crushing to the nation and such a deep
loss Alex what kinds of things does your
history book talk about well my history
book tends to actually veer away from
the subject of the controversy they tend
to it adopted the lone man theory one
with Oswald and it's just it's actually
very short and have you covered it yet
in class with a teacher no we have not
no although my school did host a seminar
on the JFK assassination which it went
into it went into some detail on the
conspiracy theory and they you they use
the Zapruder film that's what mainly
they based all all their arguments off
of as well as other other tests on
certain things such as cadavers on and
trying to disprove the pristine bullet
theory
and was that seminar your first
introduction to the subject of the
assassination or any conspiracies
theories actually I probably formed an
affinity towards just learning about
conspiracies probably from a magazine
article on the JFK assassination it just
did intrigued me so I decided to
research on it and I and then just so
hop in my school hosted a program which
was which is great Sarah what kind of
things are in your textbook about JFK um
well like we studied it last year so but
we watched a movie we watched about the
assassination watch the movie of it and
it didn't say much about the controversy
at all that's brought up now so did it
talk about the Warren Commission report
um no not really not very much did it
have any information at all about the
assassination than or any definitive
resolution to who did it or how it
happened well they add um they they had
a picture of Johnson seen in the
background with Oswald and they thought
that Johnson was in on it too so they
said something about that may be but
that was about it about the controversy
did your teacher talk about it at all
when you covered it hmm yeah did that
person introduce any other ideas that
were not textbook he said that he
thought that there was more to behind it
he thought but the Mafia and stuff
wasn't on it too he I mean I think it
was due I thought it was more than just
a lone man did you learn more from
another source than you did in school
about this and if so what other ways
have you been getting information on
this no really that's where I learned it
most about it okay how about you
Elizabeth well unfortunately we didn't
get a chance to discuss it fully in our
history class because we were all
pressed for the advanced placement exam
but it our history book I did go over it
and it didn't talk too much about it I
think would be hard for history to book
to really make a definitive answer
because no one else can I mean the
Warren Commission gave its opinion and
that is accepted by our nation for the
most part but at least by the government
as as the real
truth but I think with all the
controversy surrounding it especially
recently it seems that no one can really
give their a true answer no one knows if
there are no definite answers or if this
is still an open question which some of
you seem to be suggesting here what
would you say should be done do you
agree with this release of documents is
this one rated I think that people like
Oliver Stone who made to FK and I read
an article by Gerald Ford and everyone
comes to different conclusions with
information that they have now and it's
so opinionated and so emotional as to
what you believe that if you're really
angry with the government it's very easy
to believe that it was a government
conspiracy but if you have complete
faith in the government then you're
going to tend not to believe that so I
think one way to get around that is to
open up the files if people are
interested enough curious enough that
they can go and read the files
themselves and form personal opinions
with and everybody has the same
information so you're not you're not
dealing with people who only have some
of the information so they come to this
conclusion and then you have people that
were on the one Commission and so they
come to different conclusions but if you
open everything up then everybody's
starting with the same base so you have
a clean slate to start with I thought
the JFK movie or the Oliver Stone film
was really interesting and that it did
open this debate and it opened all these
new interest in the in the JFK
assassination but of course it can't be
taken as truth it's a film it's not a
documentary even it's just a feature
film so it's I think that it's good in
that it opened up the interest in and i
think that the CIA files should be open
and i think that a lot of people will
read them and are very interested in
what they have to say but there's always
the question will how many of the files
will be missing and what information
will be there and what information will
be left out or blacked out but i think
that it's good
they're addressing it and that they
might open it should the government do
another investigation into the
assassination no I don't think so i
think that it's all those interesting i
don't think that its recent enough to
want another investigation what will
they do Johnson's gone they can't arrest
him worry or the mom so Alex what do you
think well I feel left if the CIA
actually had involvement in it and they
did release these papers to the to the
public I think it would be an atrocity
because but if they did do that how can
we trust our government anymore there
would be uprisings and certain things I
mean maybe this is just really
speculating and being very idealistic
but I think I feel that it's actually
very realistic if the CIA was involved
in this conspiracy are you suggesting
then that if the CIA were involved that
it would be better that we don't know
that yes yes I'm saying that it would be
better because I know for a fact that I
would not be able to trust my government
if if that was the case if they were
involved in the assassination of our
country's highest executive I wouldn't I
wouldn't feel safe if they can
assassinate the president that then it
would be extremely simple to assassinate
any other person would you not want to
know then exactly who killed JFK if you
think there's any doubt I don't think
the public should know really I don't
really think they should find out
because there is the reasonable doubt
that the CIA was involved I mean who's
to say that they weren't and if they
were again i must say that there could
be just mass confusion within our
society and who knows resulting in civil
strife as well as murder anything like
that just trying to get back at the
government there would be a loss of
trust entirely actually because i don't
think the CIA is our central government
in any shape or form there's been a lot
of talk recently with the end of the
Cold War that the CIA might fall apart
entirely I think that if the we opened
up these files and we did find new
information even if it did point to the
CIA that's I don't think there's a
problem with that I don't think it would
necessarily break the trust in our
government our government has changed
since 1963 and it's I don't think it's
relevant I don't think it will change
the attitude of the people towards the
government just to CIA I think maybe to
some people it would change their
attitudes but I still agree with you the
fact that I don't think that that's a
good reason to not give out information
to the public I mean they're people now
that think that it was conspiracy and
completely blend the government and they
don't have the proof to do that and so
they're always going to be people
believing that so but if we open up the
files then I mean I don't know what
happened so but if we open up the files
and there's a chance that some of this
will become more clear and so I don't I
don't think that that's a good enough
reason to leave everything in the air
hang like this even I mean 30 years
afterwards and this is still such a
burning issue with people that it needs
to be cleared up Sarah do you agree hi
gher if I think they should tell him I
mean if they found out who did it they
should tell out and it causes problems
it's not going to totally throw out the
government I mean we still have trust in
the government would you suggest a
reopening of the investigation into the
assassination no not I mean I wouldn't
if it just comes up and someone finds
something new that's fine but I don't
think we should go all the way back 20
years ago or 30 years ago I guess but
let's say if Johnson was involved then
that would readily involve the executive
portion of our government let's say if
there were other people involved in this
conspiracy I mean a conspiracy of this
magnitude obviously you need someone
who's a very high ranking official
either in the CIA or it could even be
our president or vice president then
excuse me so so I feel
what if the government wasn't involved
and I mean I don't think it's right to
assume that Johnson had to be involved
and and this was CIA government infested
conspiracy to kill the president united
states that maybe these would clear the
government and it would instill some
needed trust now so i strongly agree
that they should open the files even if
the government was involved I don't
think there would be mass uprisings as
you suggest just because it's I don't
think it's necessary and if the
government was involved I don't think
that doesn't make me very happy i don't
think it would make much of the public
very happy and i think that if the
government was involved and that would
necessary changes and so that that sort
of thing can happen i don't think it's
right that it would have happened so
would you say that the government wasn't
involved if that's what the you said if
they found out that the government was
involved if they if they were then i
think that we need to change some things
we've talked about possible conspiracy
theories here but i was just curious
what each of your views are on what you
think really happened having read what
you've read and heard what you've heard
maybe seen the movie if you have any
feelings one way or the other if there
is a conspiracy if you believe in the
one man gone theory there's the theories
I've heard about most recently been
about the grassy knoll and there's a
program on public television that showed
some experiments done include auditory
and other experiments just trajectory
experiments and it seems to me that
there's good evidence that shows that
there there's a definite possibility of
another gunman on the grassy knoll as
well as a the government in the Book
Depository so I think that would be most
interesting to me if I were to get
involved in the research for this I saw
the same program was talking about and I
think it was Walter Cronkite anybody
else has seen it but I think that one of
the really strong arguments in that was
I think it was this one but they had
they the they had a bullet and they said
that that Oswald's one bullet went
through
Kennedy's brain and then through
Connolly's rip magic bullet yeah and and
they took a bullet of that strength I'm
not familiar with bullet terms with that
strength whatever you call it and did
these chest that was like the equivalent
of going through a brain and a bone and
one bullet couldn't do that it just
didn't work the bullet was destroyed
before it reached count before it would
reach Connolly's red and so I thought
that physical fact sort of was the best
argument that there had to have been two
gunmen along with the time restrictions
or how long it takes to fire an aim this
type of rifle say I agree with her yeah
I feel at the lone gunman theory is
totally preposterous it was it's been
proven that it's impossible for one man
to shoot with that type of rifle which
was 30 years ago and to [ __ ] the rifle
and then take aim at a moving target and
from that structure just impossible for
someone to do even the greatest marksman
could not pull off a shot like that it
was I feel that definitely there was
more than one person involved and I
think it's pointing towards the grassy
knoll theory I think that's that would
give the clearer shot and to kill
President Kennedy during that time Sarah
I agree with that I don't think I
definitely don't think it was 1,000,000
thing I think someone was behind it I'm
not sure who but our other topic today
is a look at the term electability which
we've all heard used by political
commentators and pundits to define some
of the candidates who are now in the
race for the presidential nomination and
some other candidates it's sometimes
unclear what exactly they mean but we
asked each of you to come up with your
definitions of what you think makes a
candidate electable and I'd like to go
around and find out what you've come up
with Elizabeth why find electability to
be a personal thing and in each voters
mind and for me electability involves
the issues rather than any hype or any
other personal comments towards them I
think that
and the amount of background the
candidate has behind him it has more to
say to me than any other hype could how
do you think that the people that are
using this term in particular the
political pollsters and pundits what do
you think they mean by it do you think
it's similar to your definition no i
don't i think electability in the media
sense i think you're talking about or
like electoral pundants i think would be
more of how they look i think has been
addressed and do they look like a
president could look do they have the
charisma of a president and do they have
the more respect of a president that's I
think the way that it's been used most
often okay your definition I think
though the media's definition is a
superficial one of exactly what said who
looks best who's like Clinton supposedly
electable but I think personally and we
as a nation need to Jefferson believed
that if the masses were educated about
the candidates they would choose the
right person and that's why democracy
would work and I think we need to get
back to that belief that to stop
worrying about what somebody looks like
and how the charisma of someone and get
back to the basics of elections and of
candidates of what people stand for
their beliefs their issues can i as a
voter have faith in this person to put
forth programs that we need that the
community needs and once the media get
that gets back to that then the whole
nation is going to follow and we're
going to get back to what's really
important the issues and beliefs and
whether we can trust this person to
leave the country so that would be your
definition I can we try that was
definition but but I guess a lot I mean
my definition of electability simply is
what was I do I agree with the person
with their issues and their beliefs
Sarah I think it's just the way the
person appeals to the people on how they
portray themselves how they just if
they're I think it's more people the way
they vote today is based on a lot of
people is what they look like I mean I
think George Bush's I mean he looks nice
he's tall and he's not he's pretty
skinny I mean he looks he's pretty
physically fed I think a lot of people
base it on that and but I think like
Caitlyn said we should get back to the
old way like Jefferson said and base it
on what they believe in and agree like
if we agree with them and what they can
do for us yeah I wrote a little
something on my belief of electability I
feel this this really sums up the gist
of my argument I I feel the electability
is a compilation of one's life's goals
ambitions and tragedies as well as well
as one's values and virtues learn
throughout their life therefore
electability is definitely something
that is acquired and can later give
definition to one's campaign and outcome
of their political career okay having
said that do you think that that is in
line with what you believe to be the
media's definition of electability no I
that's definitely not the media's
definition there's as as as Caitlyn said
it's very very superficial their their
definition I I I go along with what my
definition is I feel that it's it's
everything you've learned throughout
life all the people have influenced you
everyone they add to your whether you're
going to you're planning on campaigning
for something or whatever you're
planning on doing it all depends on who
influences you well there's your parents
your friends what you do and whatever
well we have for definitions none of
which match what you think the media
means by it but would you suggest that
the media stop using it or define it or
change in the way it is it needs to stop
using it because they have such immense
control over what people think and just
because they say they were saying that
Bill Clinton is electable so that's why
we're going to vote for him but as soon
as his as soon as like the flowers thing
came out like things like that then
press start saying well maybe he's not
electable so people stop looking at them
and people look to Tsongas and but now
the media staying well maybe song isn't
electable because he's not charismatic
enough why should the media decide for
the voters whether they want this person
I mean the media job is to inform and
they should stop saying who's electable
and just tell us what the people think
and then let us decide if we think
they're electable or the voters do you
think that they're using this term has
some effect on voters yeah it's great of
fact I agree i think it on the media
could do well to stay more objective
rather than subjective in their
examinations of the candidates do you
think that most people generally voters
would understand what's meant by the
media using this term what the media
means by it what do you mean if they
heard a columnist say someone someone so
is electable do you think that they
would know what that meant i don't think
so i think that's that's probably where
the difference comes in with people
being influenced by the media if they
don't understand what that means they
may think well you know maybe his his
ideas on as good as I I judged him them
to be and maybe it's not and they're not
thinking about the media judging him his
electability on his style or his Flair I
think that could influence voted do you
think that a candidate could change from
being electable to being unelectable or
vice versa yes I I feel that way
especially excuse me if you if you
excuse me if you look at the media if
you just read their reports I feel that
they tend to veer towards being very
biased at times and it's not they don't
give a candidate a fair chance and they
know that they're they have millions of
subscribers with all the newspapers they
know that people are going to read that
and they're going to form their opinion
most likely based off of what they read
and sometimes it's not the truth really
it's not quoted as the truth with that
candidate it said sometimes it's twisted
and I feel that they should at times
just try and maintain that sense of I
feel it integrity by by staying neutral
not biased like that it's very unfair
for the people Sarah if someone were
labeled unelectable a candidate do you
think they could overcome that with the
voters and actually win primary or win a
general election um it'd be really hard
but if they campaign maybe a lot in the
area where the people were most against
on maybe they could it be really hard
though for him to do it and be because
mainly I mean the meat is going to have
a great effect on the people okay we
just have a few minutes left but we do
ask you to play news editor at the end
of the program and come up with a story
this week we'd like you to talk about a
story that you think was unreported that
deserved a little more media attention
than I got this week and we'll start
with you Alex well I know one story is
that at the moment CIA intelligence has
reported that North Vietnam has nuclear
capabilities right now they're capable
of building a nuclear bomb and I feel
that that really imposes a threat and
that should be taken care of immediately
before it before they attack or anything
who knows their objective right now but
I feel that that should definitely be
looked into and the people should be
warned about that that they are working
toward getting nuclear capability yes
and people yeah I believe that way and I
think the president should look into
that definitely okay Sarah o mine was uh
how they had the New Hampshire her
caucus will prime around and um they had
so much attention there they had all the
news stations there and then they went
to South Dakota and they didn't have
very much about it so I was looking at
the paper today I didn't see very much
about I was looking forward to see how
harkin did but wasn't much about it at
all so I was kind of hoping that I think
they should cover that a little bit more
I'm going to go
Caitlin the plight of the Kurds
especially now with that Wells month all
about but the recent anniversary of the
Gulf War and how the Kurds in Iraq are
still there still living in horrible
conditions Hussein is still hot he still
has these endless um records on them and
they're still in danger of being
exterminated by him and I think our news
media has ignored them and forgotten
about them and I think we need to
remember them especially since we
encourage them to overthrow Hussein and
and did nothing about that so I think we
definitely need to remember them okay
elizabeth there was a very small article
in the new york times about a japanese
american businessmen in Los Angeles who
was murdered after a racist death threat
was made about a couple days before his
murder and then they went on to discuss
a Japanese American Girl Scouts who were
treated very poorly while trying to tell
their cookies and people were saying
they're not only by American and I think
that shows sort of this new trend in in
the American in the United States up
with this Japan bashing i think it's
it's really terrible and i think the
media has a lot to do with it the media
has been addressing it and and saying
you know showing all these comments of
japanese officials about the American
workers and I think that maybe I think
they can be held responsible for a lot
of this new job and depend another
Japanese fashion do you think the media
could do anything to stop that problem I
think I don't know what the media could
do now it's it sort of seems a little
late i think we could try to address it
though and and really see show how
negative this this new trend is and hope
that it turns around we're out of time
for today i'd like to thank you all for
your comments and for your discussion
here and thank you for watching join us
again on close up for them I man
Nicholas